welcome back I actually recorded this
video earlier today but I realized my
microphone wasn't plugged in and I won't
name names and in terms of who unplugged
it but anyway back to probability my
wife is giggling mischievously anyway so
let's do a slightly harder problem that
we did before we were dealing with fair
coins let's deal with a slightly unfair
coin let's say I have a coin and it's
actually said a fun fair coin let's
let's do basketball let's say I'm
shooting free-throws and I have a
free-throw percentage of free-throw
percentage is 80% so when I shoot a
free-throw eight out of ten times or
eighty percent of the time I will make
it but that also says that 20% of time I
will miss it so given that if I were to
take I don't know five free throws what
is the probability what is the
probability that I make at least three
of the five free throws what is the
probability let's think of it this way
what is the probability of any
particular combination of making three
out of five so what do I mean by that
let's pick let me pick a particular
combination let's say it's a basket
basket basket and then I miss miss so
that would be you know I made three out
of the five it could be I don't know
basket miss basket miss basket and
there's a bunch of them and we'll
actually try to figure out how many of
them there are but what is the
probability of this particular
combination well I have an 80% chance of
making this first basket times 80%
that's the times right there times 80%
and then what's my probability of
missing well that's 20% right times 0.2
times 0.2 so this equals 0.8 to the
third power times 0.2 squared well
what's the probability of getting this
exact combination well it's 0.8 times
then I miss that's there's a 20% chance
of that so times 0.2
times 0.8 times 0.2 times 0.8 right we
can rearrange this because when you
multiply numbers it doesn't matter what
order you multiply them in so this is
the same thing as 0.8 times 0.8 times 48
times 0.2 times 0.2 so this is also the
same thing as 0.8 to the third times 0.2
squared so pretty much any particular
the probability of getting any
particular combination of three baskets
and two misses is going to be 0.8 to the
third times 0.2 squared now what's the
total probability of getting three out
of five well it's going to be the sum of
all of these combinations you know I
could list them all but we hopefully now
are proficient enough in in in
combinatorics and combinations to figure
out how many different ways if we have
five baskets and we're picking or we
have five shots and we're picking three
of them to be the ones that are basket
shot so what do I mean so let's say my
my five shots so you know I have shot 1
2 3 4 5 and I'm going to out of these 5
I'm going to choose 3 so I'm once again
I'm putting my hat on as the god of
probability and I will choose 3 of these
shots to be the ones that happen to be
the ones that get made so essentially
out of 5 out of 5 I am choosing 3 5
choose 3 and what is that equal to
that's 5 factorial over 3 factorial
times 5 minus 3 factorial so that's 2
factorial and that equals 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 over 3 times 2
times 1 times 2 times 1 we can ignore
all the ones let's see we get 3 times 2
times 1 3 times 2 times 1 we can cancel
that this one we can ignore and then
this 2 and then this turns into 2 so
there are 10 possible combinations these
are two of them you know basket basket
basket miss miss basket miss basket miss
bass
and you know that's a it's a good
exercise for you to list the other eight
of them but using just our you know the
binomial coefficient and hopefully you
have an intuition of why that works and
I'd be happy to make more videos if you
feel that you need more explanation
whether I made a couple there are ten
combinations so essentially the
probability of getting exactly three out
of five baskets if I am an 80%
free-throw shot is going to be switch
colors the probability three out of five
baskets is going to be equal to the
probability of each of the combinations
right which is 0.8 to the third 0.8 to
the third times 0.2 squared right I make
I make three ms2 and then times the
total number of combinations right each
of these has a probability of this much
and then there's ten different
arrangements that I could make there's
ten different ways of getting three
baskets and two misses so times 10 and
what does that equal to let me get my my
high-end calculator here so let's see
what that is that is 0.8 times 0.8 times
0.8 times 0.2 times 0.2 times 10 equals
20 point four eight so it's essentially
a twenty point four eight percent chance
that I get exactly three out of five of
the baskets now let's say if let's make
it a slightly more interesting let's say
I don't want to the probability of three
out of five and then this is actually
something that probably people are more
likely to ask what is the probability
what is the probability of getting at
least three at least three baskets well
if you think about it this is the
probability this is equal to the
probability of getting three out of five
baskets plus the probability of getting
exactly four out of five
exactly five out of five baskets right
we already figured this one out that's
twenty point four eight percent so
what's the probability of getting four
out of five baskets
well once again what is four what if we
want exactly four out of five baskets so
you know an example could be how to know
Miss MIT basket basket basket basket
what's the probability of any one of the
combinations where I make four baskets
well it's going to be 0.8 to the fourth
times my and then I have a 20% chance of
that one miss right and then you know it
could have been basket miss basket
basket basket right that's the same
that's also exactly four but when you
multiply them the public of getting any
one of these particular combinations is
exactly this point eight to the fourth
times 0.2 and so how many ways can you
if I have five baskets how many ways can
I pick four of them to be the ones that
I make if I'm once again the god of
probability so this this is going to be
0.8 to the fourth times 0.2 times 0.2
times out of five baskets I'm choosing
for that I'm going to make so this is
the number of combinations where I get
four out of the five so what is five
choose four that's five factorial over
four factorial times one factorial
well that equals that equals just five
you can work that out so it's going to
be so let's just figure this out so it's
going to be 0.8 times 0.8 times 0.8 is
three times 0.8 it equals no did I do
that right
let's see point one point eight 0.8
times 0.8 yeah that's right times 0.2
times five
times five so forty point nine six
percent so this is forty point nine six
percent so roughly forty one percent
chance that I get exactly four out of
five baskets which is interesting
because that's kind of my free-throw
percentage so it's almost a little less
you know two-third shot of kind of
hitting my free-throw percentage on the
mark on that time and that's probably of
getting five out of five well there's
only one way of getting five out of five
to get it have to get all five of them
so this is 0.8 to the fifth power let me
get the calculator back so it's 0.8
times 0.08 times 0.8 times 0.8 times 0.8
times 0.8 equals 0.32 7-6 so 0.3 so 32.7
7% shot and then we could add them all
up right because we want the probability
of at least three so it's going to be
that the probability getting 5 out of 5
plus the probably getting of four out of
five which is 0.40 nine six plus the
probability of getting three out of five
so that's 0.20 four eight equals 0.9 for
208 so ninety four point two one roughly
rounding percent chance which makes
sense if I have an 80% free-throw up a
percentage on any one shot I have a very
high probability of getting at least
three out of five when I go to the
free-throw line anyway I'm all out of
time I'll see you in the next video